what's popping Kaiju it's me Mt and
welcome back to the heavy spoiler show
y'all and I hope you all like humans
dealing with Dinosaur trauma because
this is going to be a breakdown of the
Godzilla movie from 2014 a Whole Decade
ago can y'all believe that like that was
the year that I graduated college and
began my life of crippling debt good
times but anyways let's make like
Godzilla and take a big old bite into
this monster of a breakdown shall we but
yo listen real quick Godzilla's like
super power power ful with his Atomic
Breath Right but did you know that you
yes you have a special power all of your
own as well right at your finger tips
too and that power is the power to make
me and Paul's Day by using your finger
to tap that like And subscribe button
every like goes a long way to letting
YouTube know that you love what we do
here and we always appreciate it but
anyways the Godzilla movie opens up with
what appears to be an early cave wall
drawing depicting Godzilla himself as
the creature in this image was drawn
with with Godzilla's very scaly back
that immediately following this is
ancient imagery of what appears to be a
group of Christian men doing some sort
of ceremony on the back of a giant fish
this is actually Arch depicting The
Story Journey of the Irish Saint Brendan
the Navigator and how during his
seven-year journey across the ocean a
giant whale would show up every year at
Easter to allow Brendan and his
Christian homies to perform a whole Mass
on its back so needless to say whoever
wrote that story is uh very likely no
stranger to magic mushrooms after this
we can see a drawing of the iosaur
fossil The Reptilian species of lizzard
that this intro implies that Godzilla
possibly evolved from with the name
osaurus quite literally meaning fish
lizard then flashes of Charles Darwin's
on the Origins of Species appear which
is of course the famous book published
by Darwin that included his
revolutionary research on the concept of
species Evolution this is Then followed
by an ancient artwork of Heracles
fighting the mythical keto sea serpent
heavily implying here that past
sightings of Godzilla's evolving fish
lizard species could have inspired some
truth behind those Legends and this
opening also seemingly implies that
Godzilla or one of his species were
responsible for the 1898 sinking of the
USS main warship an event that would
inevitably lead to the 10-week Spanish
American war then we see reports of a
separate American military submarine
carrying 25 people sinking on the
western coast only for that submarine to
be rediscovered later with the
government denying that they had other
submarines unaccounted for which
definitely feels like monarch trying to
cover up Kaiju continued feeding on the
nuclear arsenals of navies across the
world in this Godzilla 2014 movie we can
see just how far a Kaiju can toss a
warship when the US military catches a
Muto eating all of that spicy radiation
inside of nuclear missiles from a
missing Russian warship then after this
we get a quote about Godzilla from
paleontologist Harry as lad that calls
his species a species of reptile that we
thought was extinct this animal did not
die from any event it is alive in the
Pacific with the words destroy the
creature at the bottom accompanied by a
picture of this hary lad fellow looking
downwards Harry S lad was a real life
scientist who was famous for studying
fossils in the Pacific but in the
monsterverse he did a little bit more
than dig for bones he apparently was one
of Monarch's most crucial leaders and
assets alongside a Dr Leonard Schulz and
Commander Roger Revel shortly after the
organization started to really take off
Harry S lad was exceptionally familiar
with the geology of the bikini at Old
Islands which also get referenced a
number of times during this opening as
the real life nuclear test conducted on
those islands gave the creators of the
monsterverse much creative inspiration
as we learn in this movie that the
nuclear explosions at bikini ATL weren't
actual nuclear tests at all but a secret
attempt by multinational entities to
destroy Godzilla completely and while
this intro does give us a few flashes of
imag from this event Apple TV's recent
Monarch Legacy of Monster Series gives
us a front row seat to this very attempt
to murder Godzilla and the messed up
military politics that led to that
decision but anyways right after we get
this quote from lad we see what appears
to be a military communication that
references the deputy director of
Monarch at the time and how that deputy
director strongly suggests that the
eradication of Godzilla is not only a
matter of National Security but that of
the entire planet with the deputy
director of monarch possibly referring
to Lee Shaw of Monarch Legacy of
monsters specifically when he informs
General Pucket that the atomic explosion
at bikini atal did not kill Godzilla at
all then after this we get this frame of
a map of Japan next to this piece of
quickly redacted text meant to highlight
Brian cranston's name but before it's
redacted the text says Walter Malcolm
has claimed that government men dressed
in white lap coats routinely appear at
the site and shortly after the event all
residents are Sworn to Silence the name
Walter Malcolm appears to have been made
as a reference to Brian Cron's iconic
roles as breaking bads Walter White and
Hal from Malcolm in the Middle then
later we get a paragraph of text that
references the biblical passages of job
41 Psalm
74:14 and Isaiah 27 as each of these
passages reference the mythical
Leviathan sea serpent connecting
Godzilla to yet another culture's
folklore this is next to an image of the
Argon National Laboratory at Palos Park
a laboratory built as a result of the
Manhattan Project that was eventually
tasked with producing peaceful nuclear
energy solutions for the world the Palos
Park unit also known as site a was the
site in the Argon Forest where the
world's first nuclear reactor Chicago
pile 1 was reconstructed to make a new
nuclear reactor called Chicago pile 2
but after we get old film imagery with
the Tex project Monarch on it we get a
plaque commemorating the world's first
nuclear bomb explosion at the White
Sands Missile Range range in New Mexico
the precursor to the eventual bombing of
Hiroshima Japan by the United States an
event that we learn later has deeply
scarred Dr sarawa then after we get
footage of soldiers and scientists
gearing up to explode their secret
Godzilla nuke as the soon Tobe
irradiated people of bikini atle watch
the opening credits end with that same
anti-g goodzilla nuke exploding leaving
a reign of nuclear Ash as the Godzilla
title appears having been released on
May 16th 2014 this movie's release
coincides es with the Godzilla
franchise's 60th birth year as the
original Godzilla film was released on
October 27th 1954 with the film only
needing $380 Million To Break Even
Godzilla 2014 would end up breaking in
around
$529 million bucks making it a Surefire
box office success and a strong start to
legendary's Baby monsterverse the
positive response to this movie would of
course help Gareth Edwards score his
chance at directing his own star Star
Wars film 2 years later with 2016's
Rogue one inspired very much by the slow
suspenseful buildup that made the 1975
Thriller Jaws such a beloved and
terrifying classic Gareth Edwards
emulated a lot of that tone with how he
introduces the Kaiju of this film with
Godzilla not really making an appearance
until around the 59 minute Mark of the
movie and jaw's influence is also where
the Brody family gets their name from as
the main character of Jaws is police
chief Martin Brody speaking of Godzilla
at one point the movie was going to show
Godzilla emerge out of some ice in a
Siberian Glacier at one point however
because the 2013 Superman movie Man of
Steel recently came out with a glacier
scene that was very close to their own
idea that imagery was ultimately
scrapped but anyways moving on the film
then brings us to the year 1999 as we
watch ishiro szara and his partner
Vivian Graham arrive at a universal
Western mining site ishiro szara is of
course played by iconic actor Ken
Watanabe with the character's name being
a mashup of two different names 1954
Godzilla director ishir Ro Honda as well
as Godzilla 54 character Dr dke sarawa
but anyways at this mining site miners
who thought they struck at a uranium
deposit accidentally find the
underground tomb of a dead member of
Godzilla's species along with the eggs
of the bad Kaiju of this movie with the
male Muto of the species having hatched
first and creating a trail of dirt
leading to the ocean where that Kaiju
would swim or otherwise use some Hollow
Earth portals to make their way on over
to the fictional city of jira Japan in
order to feed off of the radiation from
their nuclear reactors as they continued
their metamorphosis into the winged Muto
that would hatch in front of both Brody
men 15 years later not only did that
cocoon cause the Meltdown at the gingira
power plant that would eventually claim
the life of Sandra Brody in 1999 but
that very same cocoon hatching would of
course lead to the eventual demise of
Ford's Father Joseph as well so it's
kind of crazy how just one mining
Expedition could domino in such a crazy
way but Ford would of course get his
revenge on these mutos by murdering a
bunch of mudo babies by the end of the
film you kill my parents I kill your
kids it's the circle of life or
something like that it's been a while
since I've watched Lion King throughout
the movie these winged Kaiju species
that Godzilla would face were never
actually given a proper name they're
only referred to as Muto with Muto of
course meaning massive unidentified
terrestrial organism and not actually
the name of a particular species of
Kaiju like it literally would not be
until 2019s Godzilla Aftershock comic
that this species of Kaiju were given
the proper name titanis jinin Mushi with
jinin Mushi meaning earthquake Beetle
this insectoid species of Kaiju were
directly responsible for the near
Extinction of Godzilla's kind with
Godzilla being heavily implied to be the
very last of his species this is because
these ginin Mushi bugs made a habit of
reproducing by hunting Down Godzilla
species and laying eggs inside of their
dead bodies which is pretty hardcore
they do this in order for their babies
to have a plethora of radioactive meat
to feed on right after they hatch the
aftermath of which Dr sarawa and Graham
witnessed in the Philippines as they
stood amongst the fossilized remains of
one of Godzilla's species but anyways
when we first meet the Brody family in
1999 gingira Japan we see a young Ford
excitedly hop out of his bed to
celebrate his father's birthday however
when he does we very much see an
interesting set of plastic foreshadowing
on the ground Ford's toys appear to not
only tease Ford's future as a soldier in
the US Armed Forces but it also
foreshadows the night of his father's
death as a toy dinosaur can be seen
amongst army jeeps and a helicopter all
of which were present when the United
States Army tried to save Joseph Broly's
life during their military helicopter
ride to the USS Saratoga as a young Ford
drags his father's happy birthday banner
on the ground past his army and dinosaur
to to we can see that Ford also has a
bit of an interest in outer space as a
toy Saturn 5 rocket can be seen on the
ground as well this rocket could also be
seen as a piece of Ford foreshadowing as
it very much resembles the missile that
Ford escorts with the military on the
west coast later on in the film behind
this rocket a Japanese monster film
poster can be seen featuring a Kaiju
that looks very similar to the main big
butterfly bug baddies that Godzilla has
to exterminate later on in this movie as
young Ford sneaks a peek at his
distressed father on the phone you can
see a family photo of them all on his
computer desk that very same photo that
Joseph would later find 15 years later
in the wreckage of the quarantine jenera
and speaking of jenera fun fact the
power plant that the broes work at in
the following scene was originally going
to be set in the realworld island of
Hokkaido Japan in an earlier version of
the script but the team opted to have
this catastrophe occur in a fictional
city instead when that catastrophe
happens a young Ford Brody Witnesses the
destruction of the jira power plant from
his classroom rudely interrupting his
teacher's lesson on moth metamorphosis a
clear reference to Mathra from the
original Godzilla films as Ford looks
through his classroom window a dinosaur
skeleton can be seen below a red paper
bird hanging from the ceiling a possible
reference to both Godzilla and Rodan
respectively then we quickly transition
to the year 2014 where we meet a Ford
aged up 15 years to be played by actor
Aaron Taylor Johnson and while Aaron
Taylor Johnson was indeed director
Gareth Edwards First Choice Joseph
Gordon levit scoot McNary Caleb Landry
Jones and Henry caval were all
considered at one point for the role of
adult Ford Brody but anyways after Ford
gets home after being deployed as an
explosive ordinance disposal specialist
we see him reunite with his son who has
made him a special Banner much like Ford
did for his own dad and while Ford tucks
his son to sleep we can see in the
background that his son has drawn him a
picture of Ford on a boat because Ford
Brody himself was of course part of the
United States Navy and then after this
we all have the displeasure of having to
watch patro make out with his sister
Wanda maximoff in a Stafford University
shirt which is so weird in a post AG of
Ultron world but hey this was pre AG of
Ultron so I guess I guess it's fine I
don't know some Game of Thrones man
then the scene quickly shifts to Tokyo
Japan and Ford has to pick his father up
from jail and when they get back to
Joe's messy ass apartment Ford cannot
help but notice all the newspaper
articles and conspiracies that cover his
father's walls with one of those
articles even correctly guessing that
the bikini ATL nuclear explosions
weren't your average nuclear tests and
were actually coverups for something
much bigger and seeing all of this
craziness Ford makes a desperate plea
for his father to stop but Joe refuses
because he feels immense guilt for being
the one who sent his wife Sandra to die
and wants to prove that the jira
Meltdown was more than just some freak
accident but when he talks about his
wife notice how we see Joe's reflection
of his own face in the window very much
hearkening back to when Joe had to look
through that sealed door window to watch
his wife take her last breaths this of
course convinces Ford to join his father
in entering the bogus jenera quarantine
Zone to get back to their old house as
Ford makes his way through his old
messed up room the word Mothra can be
seen written on one of his old moth
tanks Ford didn't actually write the
word Mothra on the tank but instead
wrote the words Dad's mouth on a piece
of tape and that tape covered over
another word that ended in ra so the
dirtiness of the room made that labeling
look like Mathra another fun Mathra nod
by the set design team then after this
Ford and his father are arrested in the
quarantine Zone and brought to the
wreckage of the jira power plant just in
time for the butterfly inspired male
mudo to pop out of his cocoon and murder
a bunch of people including Ford's dad
Mr Brian cranon himself and also random
fun fact about Brian Cranston dudee has
loved monsters seemingly his entire life
so much so that Brian Cranston was
actually the voice of snard and the twin
man two of Rita's monsters in the
original Mighty Morphin Power Rangers
show Billy Cranston the blue Mighty
Morphin Power Ranger takes his last name
from Mr Brian Cranston himself and his
involvement in the show is primarily why
he was chosen to play Zordon in the 2017
Power Rangers movie so needless to say
I'm sure Brian crenson was amped to be
involved in this Godzilla production
despite his character suffering a pretty
early death and yo speaking of giant
robots fighting monsters if he didn't
already have his hands full with
directing Pacific Rim at the time guo
Del Toro was actually heavily considered
to direct this film before Gareth
Edwards was brought on board which is
kind of crazy but I'm glad things
happened the way they did because we got
two dope Monster movies from legendary
instead of just one and God do I hope
that these two franchises cross over one
day because we need to see it I want to
see Godzilla team up with a team of Jer
man let make it happen and call G modoro
to come back and make another good
Pacific r film because that last one not
for me but do you know what else was
considered a cameo from Mr Akira Takara
one of the original actors from the
classic Godzilla films who has made a
number of cameos in past Godzilla movies
a scene with Takara was filmed where he
would play an immigration officer at an
airport that interacts with Ford but
unfortunately that scene would be
deleted takara's death in 2022 made this
deleted scene takara's last ever
appearance in a Godzilla film rest in
peace King but anyways Ford is of course
brought to the USS Saratoga where he is
briefed by Monarch and the US military
about the origins of Monarch and
Humanity's history with Kaiju with doors
sarawa and Graham revealing that the
event that specifically first woke
Godzilla up in the monsterverse was the
submerging of the USS Nautilus submarine
which was actually the world's first
ever nuclear powerered submarine as soon
as that radioactive ship went deep
underwater in 1945 Godzilla's nostrils
got a tingling and that big ass
amphibious reptile woke the hell up then
then after Ford tells Monarch in the
military that his father was tracking
echolocation patterns Ford is then sent
to Honolulu Hawaii in order to catch a
flight back to San Francisco only for
Godzilla himself to make his first ever
appearance on the world stage when he
detects the presence of the male Meo
munching on some Russian nukes like
there were some Taki chips weighing a
whopping 990,000 tons and standing at
355 ft there is a reason why this
Godzilla is the king of monsters in
legendaries monsterverse he was
literally the biggest Godzilla ever made
with the original Godzilla and the new
Godzilla from Godzilla minus one both
standing at64 ft and to design
Godzilla's face to be as commanding as
possible the visual effects Department
apparently used the faces of Komodo
dragons Bears dogs and Eagles in order
to get it all just right but anyways
right after Godzilla makes a big scream
on TV Ford's son Sam wakes up from a
long night of playing with his own toy
dinosaurs in his living room much like
his dad did when he was young he then
tells his mom to check out the real
dinosaur on TV because frankly that
dinosaur was doing some pretty rad
at an airport and he didn't want Wanda
to miss it but anyways after repar and
the big butterfly yell at each other for
a bit the male mudo bugs off to go find
his girlfriend SL sister a very pregnant
sister girlfriend who just hatched in
Nevada sarawa and Graham correctly
predict that these mutos would hit
America stash of nuclear materials in
the Yuka mountains right on the border
of California with the pregnant Meo that
hit that stack
being seen fleeing the scene as she
walks over a number of Las Vegas
landmarks like Caesar's Palace and
hara's casino and right after this
images of that same Kaiju destroying the
half-scale replica of the Eiffel Tower
at the Paris Las Vegas casino can be
seen on one of Monarch's TVs then after
this Godzilla makes his big appearance
on Mainland America as he ascends onto
the Panic drivers of the Golden Gate
Bridge in San Francisco California and
fun fact Gareth Edwards actually had a
full 400t replica of the Golden Gate
Bridge built for this sequence which is
crazy dope this destruction of the
Golden Gate Bridge by Godzilla was a
significant moment in legendaries
monsterverse especially in Monarch
Legacy of monsters in that show we
learned that Kate Randa the
granddaughter of Monarch founder William
Randa was traumatized after a School Bus
full of her students plunged into the
ocean as a result of reptar's Rampage
but anyways in order to retrieve a
nuclear warhead stolen by the male Muto
Brody and a team of army Personnel
performed from a Halo jump to descend
onto San Francisco with Halo of course
standing for high altitude low opening
but what's super dope about this moment
is that while a good amount of the scene
does have CG elements they actually did
film Real skydivers diving from a plane
intercut with Studio captured imagery
Gareth Edwards purposely made this
moment Ultra Eerie suspenseful and
forboding because he wanted it to feel
like Angels descending into hell while
citing Dante's Inferno as a bit of
inspiration for him and after they land
the military is able to retrieve the
Warhead while Ford stays behind to blow
up the muto eggs I really loved how
Gareth Edwards included the female Muto
crying out in pain at the sight of her
charred destroyed eggs as it really made
these monsters truly feel like animals
just trying to survive as opposed to you
know malicious Titans purposely trying
to ruin Humanity as Ford flees from the
wrath of a pissed-off Muto he hops into
a boat called go Whale Tours with the
name go whale being a nod to Godzilla as
Godzilla's Japanese name Gojira
literally means gorilla whale so go
whale is definitely a nod to that but
anyways that is it for this breakdown of
2014's Godzilla film what an amazing way
to kick off such a great monsterverse
man like I freaking love this movie man
like Gareth Edwards should definitely
come back to direct another one of these
things but anyways you can follow me at
mastertainment on Twitter Instagram
YouTube or wherever I am on the internet
including the Guardians of the paly
podcast where me and my friends Whitney
van lanningham and Tommy Beck told just
talk about some really fun nerd
while being absolute goofballs doing it
but most importantly you can follow
heavy spoilers here on YouTube and when
you do please hit that notification Bell
so that you can get notifications every
time we upload a video and yo please
consider becoming a member of the heavy
spoilers team it's literally only 99
cents a month and that small amount
would go a long way to supporting the
channel members get early access to
videos before anybody else so if you
like what we do and want to get content
sooner than everybody else become a
member today it's only a dollar a month
but regardless thanks again for watching
this video you guys are amazing I love
you guys so much and I'll see you guys
next time goodbye